AGAIN, THIRD STRAIGHT GAME, THEY
HAVE BEEN BRUTAL FROM THREE
POINT RANGE.
THEY ARE 5 OF 23.
THE NETS ARE 6 OF 23.
DURANT.
FOUL, AND IT WAS TUCKER.
THAT WILL BE HIS FOURTH.
AND IT'S TUCKER AND DURANT,
GETTING IN TO EACH OTHER'S FACE.
TUCKER NOW YELLING AT KYRIE
IRVING.
YOU HAVE TO BE SMART.
IT WILL BE A DOUBLE TECHNICAL
FOUL, YOU DON'T A WANT TO BE ON
EJECTED.
>> I WONDER IF THEY MAY HAND OUT
ANOTHER ONE FOR A THIRD PLAYER
THAT CAME IN.
IT'S A FOUL.
THAT'S GOING TO BE HIS FOURTH.
AND DURANT SAID SOMETHING AFTER
THAT.
AND NOW, IT'S FACE TO FACE.
AND IT APPEARED TO BE SECURITY
COMING THIS TO, BECAUSE OF THE
SHOVE THERE.
IT'S HARD TO TELL IF TUCKER IS
YELLING AT IRVING OR THE
SECURITY GUARD THAT CAME
BARRELLING IN.
>> ONE OF THOSE -- OH.
I THINK IT'S A DOUBLE TECHNICAL
FOUL.
>> THAT IS FOR SURE.
>> IF YOU ARE SECURITY, YOU HAVE
TO NOT ELEVATE THE ISSUE AS
OPPOSED TO CONTROLLING IT.
>> SO, AT LEAST THESE TWO THE
TEXAS LONGHORNS WHO HAVE A
TERRIFIC RELATIONSHIP THE
EMOTION OF THE PLAYOFFS TAKING
OVER.
>> SECURITY DID A BAD JOB.
YOU DON'T COME IN PUSHING AND
SHOVING.
>> YEAH, YOU ARE RIGHT, MARK.
>> DID EVERYBODY OVER REACT?
THAT WAS LIKE NOTHING.
YOU DON'T NEED FIVE SECURITY
OFFICERS FOR WHAT?
NOTHING.
>> THEY CALLED A PERSONAL FOUL
ON P.J. TUCKER.
TUCKER NOW HAS FOUR FOULS.
AND THEY EACH GET A TECHNICAL TO
A DOUBLE TECHNICAL.
WHICH DOESN'T RESULT IN ANY
SHOT.
BUT THE RULE OF COURSE IF YOU
GAME OF THE DOUBLEHEADER.
NBA COUNT DOWN.
>> TRYING MAKE KEVIN DURANT --
>> SOME OF THEM, IT'S GOOD
DEFENSE.
BUT THESE ARE VERY, VERY
MAKEABLE SHOTS BY DURANT AND
HERE IS THE ONE THAT LED TO THE
SWARM OF SECURITY GUARDS.
>> THANKS A LOT.
>> LET'S CHECK IN WITH LISA.
>> YEAH, MIKE, P.J. TUCKER, HE
WAS GIVING HIM, GIVING DURANT SO
MUCH RESPECT, MAYBE TOO MUCH
RESPECT PUBLICALLY.
TUCKER SAID LOOK, DURANT IS
GOING TO SCORE, HE IS PROBABLY
ONE OF THE BEST